little league baseball a team from
henderson is only two wins away from
advancing to the little league world
series in williamsport pennsylvania so
these are the kids from paseo verde at
six this evening they take on the team
from utah
so paseo advanced through the losers
bracket of both the district and the
nevada state tournaments and their coach
says wow he hopes their resiliency will
get him to the promised land
we are and oh in uh basically
elimination games um you know if we'd
have lost one of those games we wouldn't
be here today but uh
being nine to no that's
i mean for any team and any at any level
uh pro or any level at all that's that's
a good accomplishment for sure it's one
pitch at a time and these kids really
believe it and to be 9-0 in elimination
games is something special that
nobody can
that's crazy in any level of sports and
i love how i don't even have to look at
jerseys i can just look at the stance
and say there's paseo verde because the
fans are amazing and they're always
there no matter what
all right so the game is on espn plus
which is a subscription service but
we'll for sure keep you posted so the
team from paseo resilient
and uh if you do watch tonight i want
you to watch out for ryland gregorich
okay he's a pitcher and a shortstop and
he's a superstar
pitcher and a shortstop oh yeah
not at the same time no
that'd be hard to do yeah but he also
swings a pretty hard bat too all right
gregory
has been doing some scouting
all right well we will look to you nate
for all the info